buenas tardes un paso importante y
necesario para empezar a establecer esta
nueva relación entre el reino unido y
europa posiblemente menos conflictiva y
también abrir las puertas para este
acuerdo comercial el parlamento
británico ha sido convocado para este 30
de diciembre para votar el acuerdo el
acuerdo de la nueva relación y el
acuerdo comerciales será una votación
que se prevé sencilla el primer ministro
tiene las mayorías el jefe de la
oposición si quiere estar me ha dicho
que no está de acuerdo con todos los
términos de este acuerdo pero lo más
razonable para salvar la economía y
salir sin acuerdo es apoyarlo pero el
scottish national party ha dicho que no
lo apoyará porque básicamente este
partido lo que quiere seguir en su
relación con la unión europea sin
embargo se prevé que será una votación
sencilla el primer ministro debe
convencer todavía a los euroescépticos
de su partido de que este es el mejor
acuerdo posible entre tanto el jefe del
gabinete británico michael gov ha dicho
que las empresas y las
deben prepararse por posibles efectos
que pueden tener a partir del primero de
enero como no tendrán que hacer tendrían
que hacer una fila diferente en los
aeropuertos y podrían tener cargos en
los servicios de rubén